are you looking for love in your real
life I'm always looking for love I'll
take as much love as I can get well it
looks like KJ Appa might have found it
we're gonna have to say 22-year old and
Britt Robertson may be more than just
co-stars I can tell you that but I know
that you're gonna find out the two
attended a comic-con party on Saturday
and according to ETS eyewitness the two
were seen packing on the PDA putting
their arms around each other holding
hands and even kissing KJ and Britt
appeared together in the 2017 movie a
dog's purpose Wow sorry that was the dog
with me maybe you should teach your dog
some manners now the two are set to star
together as love interests in the new
film I still believe a sequel to the
2018 indie I can only imagine the actor
is playing real-life Christian music
singer Jeremy camp while the 29 year old
is starring as his wife Melissa Henning
the movie which also stars Shania Twain
is set for release next year now back to
comic-con
if see caught up with KJ at the event he
was there to promote Riverdale and while
he didn't comment on his personal love
life his Riverdale co-star and on-screen
leading lady
Camilla Mendes did tease that there's a
lot more VAR g coming up on the hit CW
show I'm really excited to see what's
next for Veronica because parents are
away I'm assuming these gonna play oh
yeah we have the house to ourselves
she's gonna be throwing some wild
parties this year uh that's for parties
jeez
[Laughter]
you